welcome to this video the rematch for
the viewer challenge against it agile
agile master three minutes and two
seconds increment important to note and
for those who have not watched the the
first of the two game metea this is he's
very decently rated in the five-minute
pool but this is the blitz rating so
it's not such an uneven match as it may
be looks like at first sight okay we
have we have in Sicilia allah pin or c3
sicilian where i really have no idea
about the theory I hope I'm not in
trouble yeah but this looks this looks
like a fairly solid position not yeah
okay nothing to write home about but not
not terribly bad night b5 here to sign
don't really like hmm yeah this is feels
like a very slow muscle ok but not
beehive is a threat so we have an
endgame and we have a typical position
by black has two pawns on the queenside
and why just got three so it's a typical
three against two majority which by a
very conventional standards dating back
centuries should give white a slight
edge but he's got a double pond and the
slight edge is also not so easy to prove
in
in a practical game also um I have been
an extra center pond which is worth
something we should do is move that
surprises me I'm trying to try to play
e5 and f6 but I want to I want to make
sure that after a five-night f3 I am
interesting he wants to put it on c3
yeah well I want to play five not
shouldn't hesitate with that now maybe
nights e2 e3 this could be a good idea
actually yeah I am okay it still
shouldn't be should be a terrible
position for me this poem is controlling
some important squares and I have root
dat comin up King to e6 this is
important this f65 setup allows my king
to participate in the game and his king
is is not really playing at the moment
okay if i play with the aid he might
play Bishop f5 this is this is not not
great
huh hmm Bishop b5 oh that's annoying
really okay let's let's start start with
this fish of a 5 97 95 okay he's got
entirely different ideas
not sure what be 555 really helps them
he cannot really play c5 ever and if you
cannot do Wow yeah we know this kind
this type of situation right I'm saying
that he can never ever play that and
just as I'm telling that he's doing it
um yeah he's got that C for a five and
in fact and this may be makes it
playable at least it's a it's not not
stupid at all interesting
Knight a5 a.m. does c6 even threatening
what I'm trying to do is I'm rebooting
the bishop I want to play Bishop to d8
da to c7 that it controls a 5 95 maybe
first look-see aid to make sure he does
not have c6 a while but c6 is no threat
right okay I need to watch the clock as
well I'm 150 seconds and it's well three
minutes and two second increment is
essentially the same as as five-minute
bliss but still it's a it takes some you
need to get used to it that you start
with the with less time
is this helping getting it to d3 not
sure
looky to was interesting
I'm trying to do the way you did this
chikni if I can exchange that hmm ok why
have I completely completely overlooked
that a 6 Hanks Wow Wow time morning
the top with the porn I didn't even
recognize that okie 7 was winning and
it's increment what the heck I really
really forgot that for a moment okay for
i'd like to get counter play with our
form check
ok check
yeah cheeky I Scott whoopsie and check
check check this should be lost time I'm
cut off with the king check check check
yep check this this really winning check
check
come on don't overstep the time check
hmm I don't tell you I don't see a win
at the moment maybe it's the wrong maybe
it's the wrong check check
check king j it has even made the
self-made check check that's a goner
look age seven check check draw our
third Wow Gras our third good run ha wow
that was close that was close and not
the playing time the playing time is
coming this challenge to our four
minutes so this is another charge is 12
minutes and this is a benefit of
increment chess you really we had this
played out it wasn't decided by some
clock some clock issue and not I'm not
not positively sure royalty I'm lost
this is clear but is it lost later I'm
not not one hundred percent sure let me
let me check this here it's a draw
that's also also quite clear so here
check though it's still a win but you
shouldn't go into the corner let's see
here and now here I am that's it that's
the little thing you're you need to find
this trick so that after the capture
check check the rook is lost in the game
after he went here it's the draw that's
really it wrong check and it's easy to
draw I can I just need to stay put iam
so shouldn't go into the into the corner
yeah good good job I mean I should have
lost of course I was I was dead lost um
around here that's I'd like to check
this this position here I felt I should
be in really good shape but it really
didn't didn't materialize yeah this this
isn't good i Eve nice night takes me
seven young this is josh is strong yeah
this is a very complicated type of
middle end game that that is a tricky to
play for both sides alright an
interesting game thanks for me though
sorry thanks for watching